hey 42 here in 1796 Edward Jenner a
local doctor in Gloucestershire England
became obsessed with milkmaids
he started observing them he said it was
for medical research but we've all heard
that one before but after a while he
started to notice something peculiar all
the milkmaids were immune to smallpox a
highly virulent and common killer
disease at that time he suspected this
was because milkmaids often contracted
the relatively mild disease of cow pox
bursts which somehow made em immune to
smallpox Jena carried out a famous
experiment of an eight-year-old boy and
purposely injected him with a small
amount of the cow pox virus as Jenner
had hypothesized the Boyd was now immune
to smallpox he was so confident in his
findings that he even carried out the
same experiment on his 11 month old son
two years later Jenner publishes
research coining the word vaccine from
Latin Vaca meaning cow of course because
the Catholic Church were as usual
intimidated by Jenner's progressive
thinking they launched a smear campaign
to ridicule him and his research luckily
for millions and millions of lives
pragmatism eventually prevailed and in
1803 Jenner was awarded government
funding as the usage of vaccines became
widespread throughout Europe and the
u.s. always going very well for a couple
of hundred years but then in 1998 a
former British doctor and medical
researcher called Andrew Wakefield
published a research paper claiming that
there is a strong link between
vaccinations and the onset of autism six
years passed by and his research had led
to rumors all around the world that
vaccines cause autism to make matters
worse numerous Hollywood celebrities got
caught up in it all and publicly spoke
out about how they believe vaccines are
linked to autism and as we all know
celebrities are the fountain of all
knowledge yes I did just insulted myself
but since Wakefield claims were getting
a lot of media attention around the
world over scientific researchers and
investigative
start the to test Wakefield claims and
dig a little deeper it turned out that
all of Wakefield research was entirely
unsubstantiated and a lot of it had been
entirely falsified and then a journalist
for The Sunday Times discovered that
Wakefield had undisclosed financial
conflicts of interest naughty naughty
an investigation ensued against
Wakefield it turned out he had also
heavily mistreated autistic children
during his experiments eventually he was
completely discredited and barred from
practicing medicine in the UK ever again
of course the news of all of this didn't
get a speck of media attention
unlike the story that vaccines do cause
autism so the world was left in the dark
still believing in his fake research so
to put it simply this whole vaccine
autism rumor that spread like wildfire
and still perpetuates today was born out
of Lies and fake research so then it's
pretty clear where I'm going with this
video but let's dig a little deeper
because despite all of this happening in
2004 a recent poll reveals that 18% of
Americans still believe vaccines cause
autism including their president so how
does a vaccine work anyway well a
vaccine is basically an expansion pack
for our immune system when harmful
microbes enter our body our immune
system kicks into action and releases
antibodies little battle sister-sons
down the invading virus or bacteria and
exterminator but that's not all your
body does it also records a memory of
the configuration of that specific
pathogen and also the best way to
denature it in the future because every
pathogen is different a different
approach is needed to kill it a vaccine
contains either a very small unsafe
amount of the actual pathogen which it's
intended to protect you from or a
pathogen which is already dead
once the inactive pathogen has been
injected into our body an immune system
responses triggered and it learns
everything about that pathogen and
remembers it
if it ever comes across it again in
greater numbers our immune system is
well-prepared countless studies have
shown that this is a perfectly safe way
to immunize your body against future
infections there has been literally no
scientific evidence found suggesting
that vaccines are in any way unsafe some
complain is feeling ill laughter a
vaccine but unless by coincidence
they're not actually sick it's just
because there are side effects to our
immune system being triggered and the
side effects happen to be the same
symptoms as the flow such as excessive
sweating muscle cramps and headaches so
if it's not the active ingredient in the
vaccine the inactive pathogen that's
allegedly causing autism then what is it
well a vaccine does contain a small
number of ancillary ingredients these
additions are simply there to stimulate
your immune system and help it to do its
job against the newly introduced
pathogen so could these strange
chemicals causes any harm
well very very unlikely all the commonly
used vaccine ingredients are completely
natural and can already be found in the
human body such as aluminium and
gelatine the most controversial vaccine
ingredients has been an antiseptic and
preservative called biome Ursel which
was the main ingredient that people
believed was responsible for causing
autism although we know scientific
evidence could ever be found not
supported these claims however due to
public concern fire mercial was
immediately removed from all vaccines
across the whole of Europe and America
so it's actually no longer a concern so
how many studies been carried out to
specifically test a link between
vaccines and autism well yes
quite a few actually over 50 independent
evidence-based studies have been
conducted specifically investigating the
supposedly and all of them concluded
that there is no evidence linking the
two furthermore some studies have found
that having the large amount of vaccines
in a very short space of time as an
infant but a lot of people worry about
has no negative side effects
a growing number of people are refusing
to vaccinate their children against
deadly diseases what doing this doesn't
just affect them it's also incredibly
dangerous for the rest of humanity
because it increases the chances of
pathogens multiplying between hosts
mutating and becoming a global pandemic
so yeah just think about that next time
you base your entire scientific
consensus from an infographic you saw on
Facebook it's easy to see why some
people are so eager to make the
connection autism is typically
identified in children between the ages
of 2 & 3
however symptoms can appear between 1 &
2 although it differs from country to
country these crucial years are
typically when children are given the
majority of their major vaccines such as
measles mumps and rubella so the time
frames line up perfectly to shove the
blame onto vaccines and when backed up
by a singular scientific study albeit
falsified it's easy to see how this
rumor quickly grew into something quite
large
but if you still adamantly believe that
tweets of celebrities I post your friend
shared on Facebook and the results of a
singular study that says the improvement
Ollie untrustworthy over mountains and
mountains of evidence brought forward by
people who have dedicated their entire
lives to the study of medicine and
vaccines then I guess there's little
else I can do to change your mind if you
really do need further clarification
then I can only suggest that you visit
how do vaccines cause autism calm it
truly was an eye-opener for me thanks
for watching if we go back to the Middle
Ages or even all the way back to the
Roman Empire was life ever any better
than it is right now then you could be
an extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius-level